welcome back the Prime Minister has
promised to tackle the issues that have
led to so many young people carrying
knives this is may has been accused of
presiding over reductions in police
numbers and cuts to youth services which
have contributed perhaps to arise in
knife crime she was speaking following a
weekend in which two teenagers were
stabbed to death
17-year old Jody Chesney was killed in a
park in East London on Friday night and
the following day Yusuf Gallup Macky
also 17 was knifed in Hale Barnes in
Greater Manchester well I'm joined now
by Jennifer Blake a former gang member
and founder of the safe and sound Youth
Project which aims to reduce levels of
gang knife and gun crime among young
people Jennifer thanks very much for
joining us
so why do you think the use of knifes
our knives are is increasing and why the
victims getting younger mmm the increase
of knife is that young people is not
easy to get out of a gun so nicely easy
to obtain Amazon parents cupboards shops
are selling them so again when you say
rise in knife crime is such knife crime
has been going on for a long time I
think because the media catches on to it
there's there's more media around it but
not crime is something that's been
happening for so many years young people
have been carrying for a long time it's
because you say they can't get hold of
guns well it's hard as a geld of a gun
you know but to get old of a knife it's
so much easier and you can see that the
prices of guns on the streets just to
get out of a gun that there's a big
price for that so the easiest thing to
get old off is a knife so you're in a
gang for 10 years more than 10 years in
London did you carried a knife did you I
did it was it it was a normal thing to
carry a knife back then as it is those
young people say it is different they
used to call it a ratchet so it was like
a flick knife and it was part of my
attire it was something that I always
had and always went out with it always
went out there and you use it to
frighten people to knifepoint robberies
you know hold my hands up that is the
things that I used to do and
was completely normal well it well Harry
now so carry knives and and have my
because you worried about being yourself
threatened by me well put it this way
when you're on the street you've got to
look at things of wear how are you going
to protect yourself if you're on the
street and drugs was a thing that I was
involved in it was a thing where it's
there to protect me it's there to
frighten people you know so it was just
there today's young people in carrying
knife it's the same thing it's a thing
about protecting again you said again
when you're going to rob somebody you're
going to use a knife you're gonna
brandish a knife
whichever way so at the end of the day
there's nothing changed as much as we're
where we used to carry it it's just the
way that young people are now killing
each other yeah and you mentioned drugs
ed what is the you know what impact does
drugs particularly stunt this strong
type of skunk that can affect people
psychologically what impact does that
have do you think the smoking of the
skunk has a as a huge impact and the
fact that it's something where young
people are selling on the streets that's
the other impact to it now when you're
smoking skunk um I used to smoke and
cannabis there was a stage in the let's
say 90s late 90s where there was a lack
of commercial cannabis so if the skunk
came in and I honestly could saw the
difference in my behavior my attitude
when I smoked the skunk so there's a big
difference in the psychotic behavior
that I was displaying I see in so many
of the young people that are smoking the
skunk so so what is the way forward here
in your view you know Theresa May says
it's not about police officers on the
streets that what what in your view is
it about police officers or is it about
tackling the problem you've just been
talking about you know drugs what it
where do you think the solution or
possible solution lies
there's many solutions and I think the
problem that we're doing is that were
just we're looking at the solution of
knife crime we're not looking at
solutions of other issues that are
relating to the macro so a lot of
emphasis is placed on the knife crime
itself
we have a lot of young people that are
out there witnessing young people being
stabbed their friends being stabbed
trying to save them you know body parts
out on the road what support goes out to
those young people that's going through
that trauma to see that so we tend to
work in isolation I say we because
you've got government in one place the
police and in one place everybody's
saying something different and nobody's
coming coming together collectively to
say look this is a problem that we've
got we've got to all come together so
policing do you know what I'm s you're
going to have a police on every single
corner of a street then trying but we
can't afford that so let's let's come
together government policing health
mental health has to come into it
because there's a lot of mental health
issues that are going on with our young
people nobody listened to me when I was
explaining about my situation and and
what I was going through and I was under
the care with social circle if you have
been persuaded to leave the gang could
you have been persuaded to give up a
life of carrying a knife and a possible
life of violence I want to sit down in
sable yes because at the time it was
this glamorous lifestyle that I wanted
to live so I'm not going to say yes well
you know if I had that direction but at
the same time if I had individuals that
were listening to me like how I'm now
listening to what young people are
saying then they've they sit in a firm
setting the foundation for them to
listen to see if there's a chance for
them to move forward but I wasn't
listened to
I was just looked at as that I was rude
I was at behavior issues sent to the
court the port's dealt with it and that
was it
nobody not a social worker looked at my
situation and said well do you know what
she's being groomed into it she's been
sexually exploited into it all of that
is is ignored and was that the Kate in
your case that was what happened that is
the case in what happened and so if
someone who comes you not necessarily
the police but someone else had come to
you and said look this is what we need
to do with you you would have been
willing to try and sort of embrace that
or would it was the gang life so
exciting and it was awful so adrenalin
gave you that you know some meaning to
your life let's just say that nobody was
offering me anything different whereas
whereas if I'm speaking to a young
person I've like
experience that I'm now speaking to them
and I'm they're able to offer them
something I love a solution so if they
take it now or later one they say do you
know what I heard what Jennifer said and
you know what Jennifer I really want to
try that then that's a chance for them
but if they're not getting a solution or
they're being told is that you're bad
you know you're you're you're going to
turn out to be nothing you're going to
die you're going to end up in prison
best that's what they've got in their
head